alright let's talk about the Tea Party
those crazy koox according to a new
rasmussen poll I cannot believe this
forty-two percent of the people in
America believe in the Tea Party's basic
ideals and then another forty two
percent believe in President Obama's
basic ideals that's nuts those are
complete polar opposites and basically
half the country believes one thing half
the country believes in the other might
have something to do with our left brain
right brain thing but let's look at some
some further numbers fifty-seven percent
of GOP voters have a favorable opinion
of the Tea Party movement seventy-seven
percent of Democrats and forty-seven
percent of voters not affiliated with
either major party view the movement
unfavorably and forty-seven percent of
voters believe neither party represents
the American people thank you for that
alright so these numbers are really
interesting and there's there's a lot to
go on here but let's just start with
this 4242 thing because that seems
completely nuts to me that we could
write that well I everyone talks about
how polarized we are and of course if
you watch MSNBC you get one set of views
if you watch foxy another and webb look
there's a presidential election it's
like literally neck and neck it's very
rarely you know it's always like
49-percent 449 person but doesn't it
seem a little more extreme because the
Tea Party is more to the right obviously
than mainstream Republicans and most
people would argue that Obama's probably
a little more to the left well I would
argue that Obama is more to the right of
mainstream libs of a three have more
centrist so what I'm seeing is actually
just a big push to the right across the
board and that's what worries me more
the the issue with the Tea Party thing
and I'm gonna sound like a horrible
educational elitist here oh and they
like that around here that is because I
personally feel that knowing things is
good the part of the difficulty with the
Tea Party numbers is that it's largely
made up of the undereducated and if
you've ever been a cost it on venice
boulevard venice beach by the the people
who take surveys for the Libertarian
Party right what happens is they start
off with things that make perfect do you
believe in freedom why yes I do do you
think that individual responsibility is
a good idea why yes I do
and then you get like a third of the way
into the thing and then you won't I
can't agree with that do you believe
that the poor should be left to starve
in the street no hey where do we get
there and as with the healthcare
initiative if people hear Obamacare they
say no no no and then you break it down
into the individual elements they go
well yes I like that one well yes I like
that you can stay on your parents until
you're 26 right yes I like that you can
get health care it's the same thing that
goes on with tea party supporters you
say do you agree that the the tea party
has some good ideas yes I do do you
agree that there should be more
accountability yes I do and then they
say okay forty-two percent say tea party
go round'em a Toledo is that really an
issue with i mean III think i have to
kind of say that i probably disagree
with the premise that the majority of
tea party supporters are undereducated i
think that's like a sweeping
generalization um after the ones in
Texas I'm from Texas I know many tea
party members at eggs I didn't know I
myself am obviously a progressive voter
I don't I don't affiliate myself with
IDA party but I'm a progressive voter
and I have no interest in the Tea Party
but but I do I have to say I disagree
with that sweeping generalization I
think the issue here is more about
polling polling as it as as a as a
function to try and show a long time
since I've had a good polling good
polling argument oh yeah yeah let's have
a Polaroid really i mean i think it's
it's a thousand people it's a thousand
representative voters and then they ask
questions in a way that there's only one
or it's either this answer or that
answer or i'm not sure yeah that's
always the case so do you fundamentally
believe in the tenets of the tea party
yes or no I mean what does that mean how
inclusive is that you know just to your
point that you were just making yeah and
isn't there something a little
intellectually dishonest about sort of
what the Tea Party's doing which is they
want the government to be incredibly
small right barely exist and yet when it
comes to things like women's rights and
gay rights and stuff like that they
still want to control you so they don't
like the big thing but they want it's
ovah to fit in your bed the Tea Party is
fundamentally dishonest from the start
because it pretends to be a grassroots
organization that is strongly empower
Phylly supported by big money
interests in the forms of the Koch
brothers and I believe Roger Ailes and
other unidentified individuals with the
pockets right so that there's really a
sense of that that you can fool 51
percent of the people most of the time
and that'll be just fine I think they
pull on they pull from from two
different areas right they try to build
a grassroots movement of kind of salt of
the earth individuals who are interested
in more I'd say libertarian values and
then they combine that with this kind of
a Christian Right movement and it can
flate those two things and that's where
you see this uh this kind of
juxtaposition of we want to keep the
government out of our bedrooms but at
the same time we only want good
Christian values in our bedroom right
it's so bizarre because if they went on
the libertarian stuff I would support
that I'm a firm believer in low taxes
and having the government be basically
out of our lives but it's it's the other
part we're going to get to a story on
that so my last thing on this is the the
last number we looked at there was the
forty-seven percent believe neither
party represents them I'm gonna guess
that you guys sort of agree with that as
a general I think it's a forty seven
percent and forty-two percent one
hundred percent of the population well I
guess that was a separate right that's
another problem with polling is that if
you ask the question a certain way
you're going to get a certain response
right so 42-percent like the Tea Party
but then forty seven percent don't like
don't like anyone right mr. 42-percent
like Obama and somehow know what do you
think about that that's basically half
of the country's or is saying well we
don't like any of these guys well I
first of all we have to deal with the
myth of democracy as we run it because I
will point out we don't choose who our
candidates are we are given a set of
four or five people anointed by the
party to choose from and then we were
going to throw this mentalists trick you
guys choose between the ace of spades
and the ace of clubs you guys choose
between the ace of diamonds needs of
hearts and then you choose a diamond or
a club and then you go and complain
about the suits for a couple of years
yeah so we're already dealing with a
closed circuit of representation and we
are not being represented because
knee is what drives the whole system and
more and more money is being taken out
of the hands of the middle class II
shrinking middle class and put into the
hands of the very wealthy and the very
wealthiest was being represented so more
than 40 foot seven percent of the
population isn't me represented
regardless of how few it is that have
figured that out thus far and that's the
thing I mean it's really maybe that
forty seven percent or the individuals
who have gotten wise to the idea that oh
I think I'm tired of voting against my
own interest yeah well they're finally
getting wise hey guys the Rubin reports
brought to you by Cooper calm they have
up to seventy-five percent off pet
treats choose toys and more and if you
use code are are you get another twenty
percent that's a lot of percentage right
there I can't do that kind of math the
link is right down below Cooper calm
code RR